l'incendié avait ému dans le département
des yvelines dans la nuit du 2 au 3
novembre 2019 le chapiteau de l'arche
lieu d'initiation aux arts du cirque et
de la danse était détruit totalement par
les flammes à chanteloup les lignes
pertes matérielles chiffré à plus d'un
million d'euros causée par cet acte
volontaire près de deux ans après les
faits six personnes comparaissent à
partir de ce mercredi devant la justice
à versailles cinq personnes sont
renvoyées devant le tribunal
correctionnel est un des mis en cause a
été renvoyé devant le tribunal pour
enfants puisqu'il était mineur au moment
des faits alors ils sont renvoyés des
chefs de destruction volontaire par
incendie et donc plusieurs années de
prison également des violences assez
importante sur des forces de l'ordre le
chapiteau s'était embrasée lors de
scènes de violences urbaines qui avaient
touché le quartier de la noé vers 21h30
le 2 novembre 2019 les policiers sont
appelés pour un feu de poubelle les
forces de l'ordre doivent alors essuyé
pendant plusieurs heures des jets de
pierres et de cocktails molotov ainsi
que des tirs de mortier et ces
événements aux fêtes se sont inscrits
eux à une période c'était la fin de
l'année 2019 où il y avait eu plusieurs
événements de violences urbaines dans le
département des yvelines
donc il y avait marqué effectivement de
façon très importante cette époque là
depuis le coc vide aussi est passé entre
temps ces événements ne se sont pas
reproduits et bien sûr ce n'est pas ce
qu'on souhaite le site va renaître de
ses cendres un espace culturel est en
cours de construction en lieu et place
de l'ancienne arch quant à la compagnie
d contraire l'association qui occupaient
les lieux elle a pu reprendre ses
activités sur la dalle voisine où un
nouveau chapiteau a été dressé avec le
soutien de la région ile de france le
procès a duré deux jours les 22 et 23
septembre la justice pourrait statuer
tout de suite ou mettre sa décision en
délibéré